Rapaport still IC is here yeah on the
Rich Eisen show he is gonna be on
fantasy zone this season watch him with
Kay Adams John Hanson Jason Smith
channel 704 only on DirecTV and that's
one of the million things that this man
does get to see you bud glad to be here
rich sorry I wasn't at the draft on
Tuesday night I don't think you are
sorry that you weren't at the draft is
that because I think that Brock bring
Brockman is the brains of the operation
not only were you not at the draft it's
one thing to not be there yeah it's
another thing to not be there and just
not be there meaning you could not be
there physically and and he could be you
know like your flunky like your button
pusher you didn't have anything to do
with your team's draft Brockman would
you care to disabuse this man of that
notion please yeah actually rich was far
more involved this year than last year a
lot of communication going not a texting
back and forth we were simpatico yes we
were we were and and I was doing NFL
gameday morning season preview show at
the same time okay expertly I might add
so so this brings other of the operation
because were you getting the information
from somebody at the NFL remember that
that great Steve Martin show the man
with two brains yes that was us that was
us right I'm predicting some predicting
my team I was again you well you you
were first overall that would David
Johnson was a no-brainer
yeah sped it along right yeah and then
so then you were twenty after that do
you remember where you took really good
in a million leagues I mean yeah I came
back and I took of was it Doug Baldwin
Doug bald and and I I made a decision
and we were texting back and forth
thinking that we were gonna get him we
would have taken you to Maury right we
took him re Cooper because you took Doug
yeah I was gonna I was going back and
forth between Amari and Doug I took Doug
why just because you know it was I have
a Mari in my other leagues and I was
like this is such easy work like playing
against you like I was like I'm gonna go
with Doug and and and I feel like Doug
Baldwin
although the offensive line of Seattle
is is questionable yes
the offensive line is always
questionable they're gonna be if not in
the Superbowl
very close to being in the suburban is a
first
touchdown me in the NFL I agree a
first-rate I agree and he just doesn't
get the credit because everybody thinks
that the the Seattle Seahawks offense is
is sputters way too much so you got
Brady as your quarterback yeah DeMarco
Murray is your running back with David
Johnson terrelle pryor is a nice pick
yeah go with Doug ball when hunter Henry
is your defensive and Devante Parker
let's call a tight end tied him what I
say defensive that's okay that's alright
you are on the NFL Network and you are
an expert that's hunter Henry is the
defensive end for the San Diego Chargers
okay all right and so that's Rappaport's
delight in this league that Brockman and
I are in so give me give me some players
whose hype I should not believe give me
this week right this week for week one
your week one so you are not this not
for draft now you're talking about the
draft is over okay
mock drafting is over duress mocking
whole things over like you have a draft
okay but at this point the games are
starting this week in a matter of hours
I'm looking on my Apple watch will get
to the Apple watch later
please we're talking over your Brockman
I know when I say Apple watch it's like
you have like you like you you vomit
something up okay but we're - we're
doing a show over here got it got it got
it
Apple watch just coughed up a hair hole
over there but this week I would be
careful of Dez Bryant generous Jenkins
owns him he had two catches last year in
the two games that the Giants beat the
Dallas Cowboys yes sir
so I don't think anything's gonna change
Zeek not Zeek Dez Bryant is gonna be
ineffective against the Giants once
again okay Ben Roethlisberger loved Big
Ben I hopefully he has a healthy
season don't believe his hype in Ohio he
loves beating Ohio he loves being Ohio
on the road he stinks okay that's just a
fact okay
62 touchdowns only 24 on the road I
don't care if it's versus the Cleveland
Browns or the Cleveland clowns okay be
careful this week of the third one that
I have don't believe the hype this week
yes Brandon cooks I am NOT saying he's
not going to be a great New England
Patriot but until I see how they use him
as far as fantasy football I am NOT
putting him in my starting line I am
Marcus Peters ISM
first great defensive back yes who is
coming now into his own in year three
yes that secondary is no joke I think
that that the Chiefs are gonna start
well tonight which is another thing that
that I don't think a lot of people are
expecting I think the Chiefs will start
well tonight and have a shot and then
there's gonna be some form of a clock
management situation I promise you that
will happen tonight and that's not just
trolling here and again it's not that I
don't think Brandon cooks is gonna be
great mm-hmm but I just don't know how
he's gonna be used tonight as far as
fantasy football I would much rather go
with Hogan that's what we're thinking of
doing in our and did we do that or we
decided that we're flexing we're flexing
CJ Anderson we're on the fence between
us and CJ that's our conversation about
our flex for week one in our league our
league
well you don't have if I were you and
you want it to be a winner
now is this Rappaport's delight or
Michael Rapaport a fantasy zone me
talking Rappaport's delight yeah for the
seniors fantasy football analyst but if
I were you I would go CJ this week
that's just that's just me okay that's
just me it's gonna happen with New
England they're gonna be great they're
gonna be a machine they're not going 90
nano Apple watch what plate they're not
doing that the Giants will ruin that and
I don't know if this is this is this is
mental okay and and and it's a stupid
thing with fantasy football mental is I
like having somebody in the last game of
the week to be in your back pocket I
agree it's stupid doesn't matter when
they get the most points but for me
mentally I always want that Monday night
play so it's not all over on Sunday and
I feel helpless I want to come back in
60 seconds and get players whose hype
you do believe okay for week one okay
and there's people who actually want
your fantasy advice they called them as
they should they picked up a phone and
they called and they did all that they
know who the senior fantasy football
analyst is of fantasy zone yes right
here on DirecTV it's Michael Rapaport
back in 60 seconds
oh yeah this would be Michael Roberts
walk-off song if he played major league
baseball by the way Aaron judge hit home
run number 39 in the first inning of the
Yankees they took a quick three nothing
lead in Baltimore's that still the score
right now I don't know what the score
update is cuz I've been talking to
Michael Rapaport it's for nothing
Yankees now for nothing our our Orioles
loving member of our staff just got on
my ear so I love the fact that he
personally updated me on that score
hashtag suck it Michael Rapaport here on
the show you would you like to take some
phone calls here before I talk to the
people well before we do that actually
believe the hype whose hype should we
believe this right now Mike my cardinal
rule number one in fantasy football is
there are no feelings in fantasy
football there's no feelings there's no
friends or your sentimentality okay
that's my Kartal rule but I am going to
believe the hype this weekend with
Adrian Peterson if there is any
assemblance of any Adrian Peterson left
and Adrian Peterson the running back for
the Saints it will happen this week he's
going back to the house and Adrian built
everybody knows this yes if Adrian
Peterson is going to have a productive
year in any way shape or form it will
happen this week but the problem is
though is that he was named co starter
with Mike Ingram this week and then
there's Alvin Kamara sitting there I
know so you have no you know it's I said
I was breaking cardinal rule number one
I know that but the question is is is
that's the problem with fantasy plays in
also baseball when Joe Maddon used to
manage for instance the Tampa Bay Rays
you had no idea who the hell he was
starting because he's doing his Joe
Maddon thing easy
so you even even even Evan Longoria
wasn't a safe play sometimes because you
have no idea what the hell he was gonna
be doing with him I don't know where to
draft these guys in this draft and when
to play them now I understand that he
might you know Sean Payton might use him
in a in a revenge mode this week right
and but I'm saying if there's something
left in the tank they're gonna you're
going to see it this week on it like if
he if he's got something left you're
going to see it in Minnesota week one
he's not injured he's rested and there
is that emotion effect there's that
so factor he's gonna want to show out
Peyton's gonna want to have him show out
and and that's my guy who I would say
bet on also who else would these are
these are people we actually typing but
you still got him on your note so that
we know I got uh sorry well actually
todd gurley believe that hype believe
that hype this week anything going
against Indiana go for it okay there'd
air defenses a mess their offenses a
mess nobody has seen Andrew Luck I have
you seen him no no no week we won't even
see him this week and we never literally
like see him Brockman and I drafted
Cooper cop that would be that would be
the real deal spur Gers to cojones flex
play because or we're gonna be one of
those fantasy players well we got to see
something from him first and then miss
like two hundred yards right two
touchdowns Michael Rapaport senior
fantasy analyst of DIRECTV's fantasy
zone okay Adams John Hanson and Jason
Smith channel 704 only on DirecTV
our number is 844 204 rich number two
Donal ready to take some calls
mhm okay here we go I don't see advice
mat Tennessee you're here with Michael
Rapaport hey Mike how you doing thank
you hey pretty good man I kind of want
to run by you my team real quick to see
what you think about it it also tell you
about the person who loses okay go real
quick man is because the thing is with
fantasy teams it's like somebody's bad
beaten poker we all have one you know
what I'm saying go for it I got Rogers
Freeman Abdullah Cooper Decker Hertz
Kelly from Washington and I got the Rams
defense and Adam Andheri we picked up
the Rams defense this week as I think
they're gonna have a field day against
Scott tell you yeah okay they're a mess
and what's your what's your question
because you have you have access to a
great fantasy mind here and if you just
want to like shake hands and say yeah
that's it that's a fine team we can do
that but but if I were you I'd ask me
some advice because you're getting it
for free we'll see um I got a I got a
either Zach Ertz or Coby Fleener what do
you think that Kurt's
okay deckers that's what I'll do but it
can I tell you guys my whoever loses the
this year with men okay I'll make only
last few years
whoever draws a number it's to choose
the penalty right okay okay well I've
lost the last few years in March Madness
this year I gotta draw the number yeah
okay
and yeah okay so the loser has to dress
and drag oh I do that everyday looks
like mrs. Doubtfire sitting here right
now Matt in challenge cop to a dance-off
and you gotta find one that actually
antiseptic
thank you Matt preciate it there you go
just cut him off I don't know where that
was going in Robert and Fresno
California you're on with Michael
Rapaport here under what's up Bobby how
you doing I'm good I drafted two weeks
ago and two weeks after my or two days
after my draft I'm number two running
back that I turn has my sixth round pick
Spencer I'm gonna stop you right now I'm
gonna stop you right now okay it's
amateur hour
yeah you had your draft in what in July
okay you're talking to senior fantasy
football annals I stop you right now man
I blame you I blame your league I brain
blame your friends and that are in the
league and in their spouses I blame you
you're you're responsible for this you
don't do you draft in July what's the
matter with you you wouldn't come
complain to Rich Eisen about it we did
it two weeks ago that's July right
what's your quick question Robert ruddy
God Oh
besides clean punch did I look too
trying replacement because a manager
cream hunt is not gonna let him go okay
there you go Ron well what was the
question well what about the kid from
thanks for calling what about the kid
from Seattle that our our listener threw
out there right the third stringer in
Seattle he said is gonna be it's the
Google in front of you Chris you wanna
look up at the Carson he's so mo running
back since I said Chris Carson may be a
guy this week fourth guy if you're in a
league you got to start looking wrong
that's my biggest improvement ditional
what is you is is you know waiver wire
pick
get up guys early that that's the
biggest thing for me as a fantasy
football player / expert / senior
analyst that that's what I'm I got a say
I very rarely say this to the
listenership or viewership of this show
what's this you're gonna be here a lot
this fall if we're gonna open the phone
lines up you got to be quick you got to
be concise you got to be direct I don't
want to hear your team and I don't want
to hear your tales of woe and whether
you're gonna be doing
The Birdcage with a cop or anything like
that talk to rich eyes and get some
advice you're saying right wait Sarah P
don't call here for therapy this is
we're not doing mental mental health
therapy here what is your take Michael
Rapaport on the iWatch situation with
the Red Sox and the Yankees when I say
Pete Rose I mean Pete Rose now we don't
know who did what
okay but Pete Rose is down in Vegas
signing autographs for $15 a pop he's
been thrown out of baseball
I know stealing signs is sort of you
know okay but you can't cheat cheating
that's just lazy
cheating if you're gonna cheat do it
like a man okay now I don't know exactly
what happens it hasn't been documented
it hasn't been you know sort of come to
terms with it but as far as I'm
concerned if that Coach is is stealing
signs with an iWatch he should be out of
baseball straight up and down like even
little leaguers and they're all on their
watches and their phones even they
wouldn't do a something as conniving and
dastardly is that Boston sports should
be ashamed of themselves when will it
end
did you hear what Dustin Pedroia said
about what did he say he said we're here
to play baseball we have a three and a
half game lead in our division other
than that nobody gives it s yeah I give
an S Dustin for just you know of course
our white guy with a motor would say
that you know and I would she see
Sabathia
maybe I meet you in centerfield tough
guy I don't like it I think that it's
honestly when they figure it out if that
coach was doing that bye-bye you send
them down to Vegas and bring Charlie
hustle back to the major leagues I'm I
think when you bring technology into the
equation like that
that's the like but if you're on second
base and the signs are so easily to be
stolen that's great
oh god bless you you could do that in
basketball you could do it in football
I'm doing signs here but let's say
you're saying to me Rappaport I'm dying
here I need a piece of advice okay and
and Brockman's over there like yeah tell
him to pick up Chris Hogan and I go well
you know rich you know Chris Hogan
you're gonna be like I thought you were
senior fantasy football analyst you
think what I'm doing just bounced off
the chair they bounce you could steal
signs off of in the Major League
Baseball if you're a professional
baseball coach why do you even have a
watch on focus on the game Jeter because
the timing detect the times on the on
the scoreboard the times out leads to
know what time it is Jeter
Dustin Pedroia were just focused we'll
see in the playoffs we'll see in the
playoffs karma is a beat Claire amazes
me it's not a P petraea
Karma's a B and he doesn't give an S
nope I love it I love it too I mean what
do you think about it Richie I don't
know I said that that once you start
conniving using a watch that that is
beyond the pale especially since it says
in the way it doesn't say anything in
the rules about not stealing signs it
says something the rules about not being
able to have technology in the dug so
you want to go on record and throw in
this bum out is well I don't know but I
don't think about throwing the bum out
but I think that they should what the
trainer the trainer that's the same way
like the guy who apparently stuck pins
in a football you should be you should
be ejected from football forever oh you
mean the ball boy the boy whatever
whatever the heck he was we haven't seen
it heard we haven't we haven't seen or
heard from him because I think he's on a
fat farm he's losing weight that guy you
mean science where is that guy I don't
know yeah he's someplace in New
Hampshire yeah I'm sure he is I'm sure
Tom Brady got him in a nice cabin tucked
away somewhere really nice but oh it was
just stravsky wasn't it the difference
of the gentleman man you want to go out
of your way to pronounce this deflating
cheaters name correctly it's whatever we
call it rich we'll call it up on your
fire I would say I'd ask you to call it
up on your watch but it bounced about
five feet away by the way nice
thank you look forward to seeing you
this Sunday and every Sunday on fantasy
zone Michael wrap I can't wait to be
there excellent and I appreciate you
have it I do we face him in week one we
don't know we're playing Jerry Cantrell
wakelock that's just Super Bowl rematch
this is great just like last year's NFL
kickoff we're gonna exorcise some demons
- ha ha ha ha I like it let's just hope
it's a different result let's hope the
runner-up actually wins as opposed to
last year's rematch good to see you sir
take Michael Rapaport I'll give you my
two cents and how I see tonight playing
out and setting up our Friday show when
we come back the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to